[Music]
[Music]
we hear next from Vicki bread has
stimulated a lot of recollections and I
think I'll have to curb myself from
referring to rattlesnakes in the desert
there were a Bolivian revolution
encountered by that group on and on and
[Music]
the other thing that comes to mind is
Zacharias once saying that we have
accelerators like other people have mice
and in any case Vicki needs no
introduction I only need note that he
was one of the prime people Zack turned
to to build on what was already here and
Vicki responded with his usual good
measure I think fred has touched on much
of it I don't need to repeat it so I
simply turned to I think we know him as
the never cool and forever passionate
Vicki
[Music]
[Applause]
now let's install this
No
that okay you hear me well I am supposed
to talk about my life LNS in the
framework of the old days
so that is perfectly correct since I
belong to the old days it's of course
very difficult to speak in 46 years
which I spent here in 35 minutes but I
will try we will see how far I come you
see I came actually to this country 55
years ago first to Rochester where I got
an offer as an instructor and then
assistant professor and in 43 Oklahoma
asked me to come to Los Alamos and all
the time in Rochester my wife and I
wanted actually to come to the Cambridge
area where there is so much culture
music and everything science so many
facts so we were very happy when at the
end of Salamis where we became so
terribly famous for making this terrible
weapon we that dark areas came to hire
people for MIT
well MIT is in Cambridge so I was very
glad about this and accepted right away
together as you know he came there to
get a few people over here among others
Boone or Rossi Martin Deutsch would ward
and and so on us and - we were supposed
to start here the fundamental physics
which was
already here but perhaps not very active
so it was a pleasure to come here and
begin again to deal with physics with
real physics after what we had to do in
the Salamis now Zacharias
promised a easy life here he said he
spoke about LNS the laboratory nuclear
science will be established and will
help us in every respect and it did and
I must say with a certain pride and
perhaps a certain shamed that in all my
life I never wrote a request for money
to Washington because all this was done
by LNS I made a plea and others so I
just had told them what I want and I got
it now I think that I'm not sure whether
it's unique but I think it is unique
that to spend a active scientific life
and never write a proposal and I will
stick to it to the end of my life now I
came 1946 and of course at that time at
the beginning of 1946 and it was very
difficult to find housing here
we had trouble and my family we the
small children had to live in Cape Cod
for half a year because the house wasn't
ready and but it was great fun to be
really back again in fundamental physics
nuclear physics of course was also done
in the Salamis but field theory
electrodynamics and all this and to work
with such wonderful people
first of all German Fishbach I will talk
about this later and this the young
staff here and the poor stalks from
Friedman who unfortunately is no longer
with us
John Blatt almost a shallot
and on on da and some others and
graduate students and I must say I
really had excellent graduate students
and I mentioned only a few boos French
Murray gell-mann rotgut freed after
comin Dave peasley Kirsten Wang and so
on now back to physics of course physics
activities at that time were interrupted
by sort of physics and real politics by
talks about the bomb and the desire of
had have an International Committee to
deal with nuclear affairs to begin with
the Federation of American scientists
and the Emergency Committee against
nuclear war with Einstein and all this
so it wasn't only physics but it was
mostly physics the beginning of course
of all that returned to physics was the
Shelter Island confidence in 1947 that
Oppenheimer
organized and and they're organized
where we discussed all the where we have
to get again into the work and that was
of course a sensational meeting because
lamb rather Ford announced the
measurement of the lamb shift at that
time and let me just tell you an
anecdote to describe the to describe the
the fame of the of the physicists at
that time because of the bomb that ended
the war at the end of the conference
Oklahoma had to go very quickly to
Cambridge because that was a time in
Marshall
so what's the food supposed to announce
the mash of them and obi-wan I wanted to
be there so he hired a plane and invited
a few people who never see myself and
sing come on also I'm on fish by two to
go with him in that plane and it was a
little plane and the weather became very
nasty and in New London the pilot said
but I don't know what to do because I
should actually land it's too dangerous
but on the other hand the airport in New
London is a military airport and I'm not
allowed to land there and opie said to
him well do it anyway so and there was
already you could already see is Sergent
there with a red face crossing us and
giving us and we are not supposed to
land and poor pilot was unhappy and opie
said to him let me handle this
and so we landed Oh big got out and he
is this man crushing us and he said I am
dr. Oppenheimer and then this surgeon
that I use the Oppenheimer and he said I
am a we are coming from a nuclear
conference so he was the so right away
red carpet was put on the floor he were
invited to breakfast of the Admiral he
ran that place and we were honored and
shipped in a bus directly to Cambridge
so you see at that time nuclear
physicists had a certain pool
good now it was they shared the island
comprehensive course had an enormous
effect and especially on a part of my
physics activities namely together with
Bruce French we try to calculate the
Lamb shift we even started before the
experiment was done but we didn't work
very hard that's typical for an theorist
if there is no experiment well of the
theorists of these times and there was
no experiments is therefore we didn't
work very hard but when the experiment
was out Bruce and I work day and night
and actually got I should actually
mention that Hans bethe produced in his
usual quick intelligence at the Shelter
Island a semi-quantitative theory of the
effect only the constants were not quite
determined yet and we calculated the
whole thing and got the right result and
then came but the dark days of my life
namely that we were really the first
ones who had made that calculation but
we showed it to shrink and trained man
and swinger environment we calculated it
and got a different result but both
schwinger and Feynman got the same
result
under these conditions of course that
you have a difficult time now instead of
sticking to our to our calculations we
should have done we can e calculate
recalculate until half year later I got
a telephone call from Fineman you are
right and we are wrong so and then they
we are not the first it was the lamp and
crawl who did a similar calculation well
you better have self-confidence now
so the my interest at that time and
interest of the theoretical group we're
very much divided between
fundamental electrodynamics field theory
in other words and and nuclear physics
and of course after our calculation of
it was a very complicated one
I got the idea actually from Thomas you
should do calculate the self energy of
the free electron and Estelle since I
have calculated self energies for a long
time before and I should calculate that
the self energy of the bound electron in
hydrogen and then subtract but reporting
to infinity such a difficult job and we
did it in a sort of clumsy but correct
way then came with all this was of
course cleared up and made very elegant
by shrink Fineman tominaga dyson and so
on so our calculation has only
historical interest but in nuclear
physics it was in some ways a
continuation of the work I did in Los
Alamos but I had several great
advantages first and I would like to
mention it again the wonderful support
from LNS that i don't need to worry
about money and support and paying
assistants and postgraduates and and the
greatest advantage of all was to have
met Herman Feshbach here and then began
right from the beginning an extremely
fruitful collaboration of two people who
I think at least personally and not so
different but in their approach to
physics we were just different and just
complement and wonderfully complimentary
I am more intuitive or shall we say more
sloppy hand waving in my way of doing
physics he is more mathematical
formalistic
and that is it but still appreciate also
the general aspect and so we had a
wonderful team together different
approaches but not different characters
it was wonderful mutual understanding
not only from for physics but of all
problems we meet political there's a
deep friendship it lasted it still
becomes stronger every year in physics
in scientific politics in real politics
and families so well if it's not time
enough to mention what we did together
but it clouded the crystal ball model
was one of the important things which
explained measurements by and by at
Marshall the very proud and our theories
give exactly in a curve almost exactly
the curve that they are measured but let
me say one of the more important things
of that time was that the book the book
but it should be black and white
softball I decided to roughly in the
late forties that such a book should be
written
there was only one book available the
so-called Bible of hands Beatty and
Barker and others that was published
before the war so there was a really a
need for theoretical nuclear physics
book and I had again the luck of finding
a postdoc John Blatt who came he made
his PhD at Cornell who came and asked
him to work with me and he that was
again a wonderful combination now I
would like to make sure that it is not
like the famous combination of Landau
and Lifshitz where people said that
there is no word written by Landau and
no idea
conceived beneficence but it wasn't that
way there were lots of words written by
Blatt and he contributed a lot of ideas
and but he was a much more accurate than
he didn't allow any he it's a very good
mathematician he didn't allow
hand-waving
arguments and things of this kind and
also he made me work I remember when se
came in the morning and said to him
yesterday I saw a very interesting movie
he said you were at a movie you should
have a little chapter 13 and so he
really kept me working extremely hard
and then wherever there was an
interesting conflict with Riley the
publisher because I sent in the
manuscript yeah I always stick to the
alphabetical order blood and why scoff
and that reason is because my first
paper which had some influence on
physics was one with Wigner and I had
the luck to find a famous collaborator
who is in the alphabet after me so it
was a vice coffin Vigna and then I made
a vow that from now on er since my name
was the first one in this in that paper
of the natural language which most of
you know they I made a vow I will never
change and I will always publish in
alphabetical order so I went to Bailey
and said this is blood and vice cough
and why he said that we cannot do this
you are the way you are known you're the
senior also it must be by sovereign plan
the nice a fourtwenty my said they made
a vow said what that is none of our
concern we are concerned about selling
the book and then finally I convinced
him is the following argument when it is
Weiss girlfriend Platt the emphasis from
black when they display the Vice cops
the emphasis is bicycle
and he bought that he bought this and
finally it was it was blood and bicycle
well I have made the experience in
writing this book and experience in the
head later on also it is really
wonderful to write a book well it's not
wonderful debatable it's a terrible work
it always takes 10 times more time than
you think
but it is wonderful in the following way
that you really have to think about
everything and therefore you find in
writing a book themes for original work
that has to be worked out this has to be
worked out and so it was also with that
that a lot of original papers came from
writing this book among others the
calculation of gamma ray radiation which
is I think the only place where my name
enters into the language of physics with
with the so called waste of unit and
other things the collaboration with
Valeska who is here hope here and go
miss about nuclear matter and quite a
lot of things came out of writing that
book and at the end of course in some
ways also the clouded crystal ball work
with Herman Fishburne and the compound
nucleus work with Francis Friedman a
compound loose and directly reactions
thinks that later on were really
developed into a systematic theory of
nuclear reactions by Herman Fishman
we well the field theory wasn't
completely neglected I tried to
calculate with him with the person one
the magnetic moment of nucleons it was a
pre quark time and nowadays it turns out
that with works you can also not explain
it so easily but we tried to did it
differently which was prob it's probably
not very important paper and then the
independent particle model at that time
of course it was a time when the the the
shared model of the nucleus was produced
by incident maya and everybody was
astonished her from that the nucleons
run almost like independent particles in
the nucleus
although d the actually so strong and
well we try to think about this and
wrote a few papers about how this really
comes about all of this became also the
collaboration with shallot in valencia
and Gomez and then the back model the
back model the famous MIT back model was
of course one of the triumphs of this
place of the theoretical division and
where I didn't contribute much I
encouraged people like Johnson they
can't Johnson and the Bob Jaffe and and
others to go ahead I found it extremely
interesting I completed a few hand
waving as usual hand waving arguments
but well they put my name on the paper
and we regret that they did but I'm not
sure I deserve it but way I would like
to show this picture which shows sort of
the MIT collaboration in theoretical
physics
yes you see here well this is John black
that is Bruce French that's Herman and
that's me when I was still young and
black so this sort of symbolizes the way
we work and had wonderful time together
well now let me say a few words about
other activities which has more of
social educational significance I try to
introduce a few things that were fun but
didn't really develop tumor first in the
50s
I had the graduate student dinner we
went out once a month I think a week no
once a month I think more frequent to
have dinner together downtown with the
gathered students or with some of the
graduate students in theory and they
were really very helpful it was
wonderful we discussed of course mainly
physics but not only physics also
politics and and general questions
personal questions you know it's very
interesting the relation to the graduate
students has sort of changed but that is
due not only due to the changes in our
society but also due to age the
difference in age becomes bigger between
graduate students and me for example in
Rochester I was almost the same age as
the graduate students and therefore at
the beginning here
therefore they came to me also with
problems should I marry this girl or not
in which case I always say if you ask
the answer is No
but of course now this is no longer that
way first of all well I don't want to go
in this social in in some aspects of our
society but the whole this problem has
changed to not only quick only physics
now then I tried to do something which I
found that useful but then it was too
hard on me
namely a colloquium question it turned
out that the Godwit students did not
come or only a few came to the Columbia
and then I said that's really bad
because it's sad instructive but I know
the reason because the speakers are
usually not very good in the colloquium
and then I tried to do the following I
said to the so called a colloquium on
Thursday two o'clock I invited the
graduate students to come and I will
tell them what I think the speaker is
going to say now that's sometimes very
difficult first of all I only know the
title sometimes of course it's a little
more about it but sometimes I have to
guess and I told them things that maybe
they are interesting for the graduate
students but had nothing to do with the
colloquium and sometimes it was useful
and indeed I think it has helped that it
helped me enormously because I had to
think about what the title may mean and
I since I am always against
specialization I think we one ought to
have at least in Scientific American
idea of all physics not only one
specialty in other words I prefer to
know instead of knowing everything about
nothing I prefer to know nothing about
every
and this was always my son in life then
I had also a seminar how to give a
lecture and there I had there were not
more than 12 people and they had to give
a like they have to choose a subject and
preferably not their own thesis subject
but another subject and then they had to
give a talk for one hour and the second
hour of the seminar we criticized him
you didn't explain this you didn't
explain that you started you assumed
that everybody knows the foundations
which is always a mistake not only of
young speakers or but also of of all the
physicists and so that was fun but it
also somehow lasted a few years and did
not longer well then of course a very
important event in my life was
absolutely was 1960 when the director of
CERN Barker died in an airplane accident
and the moment I heard this I thought
that means something in my life because
I was always following very closely what
happens in Europe European physics and I
tried also to help with advice and spend
my sabbatical so were there since
somehow I find physics must be
international and that's one reason and
European physics after all has really
created physics and somehow the ravages
of war were terrible and we have to help
them and I also felt a feeling of how
shall I say of
Oh Europe so much the whole culture the
my education in spite of the terrible
things that happened there it is in
Europe where are many of my cultural
roots lie and I felt I would like to pay
back this some of this step and when I
then was asked to become
director-general
I accepted mainly because of that reason
but also because I never had an
administrative job except that I was
mayor of Los Alamos which is sort of a
ridiculous job but I was elected elected
mayor for two years which is great fun
but that doesn't come here you can read
it in my autobiography and then another
reason which I never admitted of course
was that I love skiing and of course
Geneva is a wonderful Centre for skiing
over the weekends so but I never
admitted that reason and God punished me
to me for this because I had another bad
automobile accident just when I started
becoming director so that the skiing had
two years no skiing
well but anyway it was for me a
tremendous experience not only from the
political point of view that you it's
the first week international institution
that is not only paper shuffling like
the many you know UN organizations but
their real work is done on the
international basis the people where the
European nations work together and also
a lot of Americans and that was really
for me and an enormous experience almost
or perhaps even more important than the
Los Alamos experience of of creating an
international spirit and it was the
first year where the machines were
working where the search has to be
organized it was just
a great thing and they must say he
enjoyed every minute of my directorship
although there were many difficult
problems but actually the collaboration
was no problem
I once a journalist came to me and said
asked me is it not very hard to have
British and French and Germans and
Italians working together I said that is
not hard at all what is hard is to have
two Italians work together and that was
just after had a discussion with the key
key in Dubya well when I came back I
didn't want to spend my life maybe I
should have stayed a little longer
because the addition of five years has
been kept and I think it's a little too
short for a Director General but I came
back after all my children and friends
and so on and they don't want to live
all the time over there
they came back sort of it's a different
person in a way because I have this
administrative experience so they made
they asked me after a year to become the
head of department physics department
which I accepted but I you see I was a
little different from the other hands
because at CERN there were so many very
good people with experience who took
over the job of the financing and you
know in other words I could delegate
authority and really think about the
important thing and I tried to do this
also in the department where it's much
more difficult because the department is
much more varied than a laboratory like
CERN but I again I ascribe it in some
ways to my laziness I don't want to go
into details of the finances leave the
store and I had the good helpers
that peed gold so many of you remember I
heal and then Tony French who were my
right hands and so I really could do it
and at that time thinks well not so bad
as they are now I mean it was much
easier to get money indeed at that time
basic science was very well supported by
Washington and that's why it was
possible to hire very good people
especially in theory no we had when it
siano who is here
fortunately as a guest and then Sergio
Fubini and Steve Weinberg and so we had
really a wonderful addition and it was a
pleasure in a way to be head of
department although it does cut is all
my colleagues who were head of
departments I can admit it cuts into
your physics time maybe not with Herman
Feshbach or Samantha works 48 hours a
day and that then he s time for physics
well I'm now coming to the time where I
was getting old I retired on the
quotation mark and 74 and since then my
my activities sort of decreased but
still it is what I was able to write
books my autobiography and other books
and and the book we could gottfried on
the concepts of particle physics which
was not the most stolen book of the
library as blood and bicycle wars and
the I'm not sure with it still is
but then you know when you get old it is
a little harder to do physics and to
understand physics what's going on
and I what I would call myself now to be
a passive physicist I like to hear and
there are wonderful friends who always
have the patience to come to my office
to explain in detail and who don't mind
my stupid questions maybe sometimes they
enjoy it even the quite a number of
people like Bob Jaffe Ken Johnson and
Alan Guth and many others who tell me
what's going on and the experimenters I
mean Henry Kendall and fan and Francis
Friedman and tell me what's going on and
I enjoy this and then altering other
feeds in solid state Costner and Virgil
now when he still works with that and so
it was a pleasure to to listen to
physics and it's still my pleasure to
listen physics but because physics is
still terribly exciting and but of
course when you are getting old you also
want to do some things which you could
always postpone interested in other
things do more music do more reading do
more traveling and I but still I find I
am still trying to be a member of this
community and every time I come and I
come less frequent and before I feel
these are friends and here's my home and
of course I made two physical
observations experimental observations
one is that
grunts now faster than before now
whether that's physics or not I don't
know
and also gravity becomes stronger
because it's much harder for me to go up
the stairs than before well thank you
very much
you